[Music]
I was always quite into having my own
style I guess I just actually for
teachers like sewing but I liked what
you could do with it I always had
something quite different than you and I
sort of like that just became very much
what I did is I went into fashion
[Music]
the ar-15 I used to go and buy fabric in
the daytime with my pocket money and
then make something in the afternoon
learning where at in the evening I was
always very observant about how people
looked
they wore how they express themselves
hence you know became a new romantic
there was a strange and Boy George and
Spandau Ballet you know we were the
Blitz kids quite influential at the time
and we've all involved do something
quite creative with their lives it was a
great time to be a fashion student
I just slowly became aware to costume
houses over the whole side of design
that I didn't really know about I did
realize I love a narrative I like the
fact that you use costumes to tell a
story and to create character and the
more I did it the more I realized that
something that I really really enjoyed
you know the story you know what they're
doing you know what their relationships
are you need to show that somehow in
cloth in a period piece you can look at
replicas what did they wear in Holland
in black you know you have the evidence
and then you can play within that in the
trend is much harder in a way because
you have to make it up I just look all
the time even if I'm not working on
something I'll make scrapbooks when I
see an image I'll just stick it in like
a Circe file or whatever and I'll just
keep putting things and it just might be
a texture so when it comes around to
starting a game I'll have a little sort
of file of ideas which just might
influence the way it goes and it often
happens like a god I forgot about that
that would be quite an interesting way
but also what you've done before sort of
informs you where you need to go
[Music]
designing a series like this first let
us come from the script that guides you
then you start building up a preacher of
how this person lives and what
influences them as they're on the coast
they can trade and they can buy and they
can become much more flamboyant there's
competition because there's more than
one armor or more than one dressmaker
it's winter so what do people do in the
evenings
well they [ __ ] embroider
to balance that with the other
characters around them and consider the
set colors and it just evolves I enjoy
doing this for women very much
Arion Danny and with answer and Cersei
because it just really could come very
strong
I like the initial designing and
planning and coming up with the sort of
ideas for characters working as a team
to make that happen when you finish the
film or a TV series I think that's it
that's your body of work you feel like
you've really contributed something
[Music]
enemies to these enemies to the west
[Music]
enemies to the south and the mr. the
north whatever stands in our way we will
defeat it with an eye
I was born to rule the Seven Kingdoms
and I will
[Music]
you just found that God as a God yet
here you stand
best help against the coming storm
if we don't put aside our enmities and
bound together we will die
then it doesn't matter whose skeleton
sits on the Iron Throne
[Music]
the Great Wall is he
you
you